الى ملف حربي روسي على اوكرانيا حيث شاهدت
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كياز دويه صفرات
الانذار مجددا وصباح اليوم قال رئيس
الاداره العسكريه في كيف ان هجوما صاروخيه
روسيا استادف منشاه للبنيه التحتيه
والنشظايا احد الصواريخ سقط في حي هولتاز
دون وقوع اصابات الجديد نتابعه من اكياس
مع مراسله الجزيره كاترين حنا ونعرض
الموقف من الجانب الروسي مع رانيا تريدي
كاترين ما تفاصيل القصر الروسي على كيفك
نعم جلال قبل نحوي ساعه من الان دوت
صفراته الانذار مجددا في العاصمه كياز
واعلنت حاله الانذار
الجوي في هذه الاثناء تحلق الصواريخ
الروسيه في اجواء اكياس وتعمل الدفاعات
الجويه المستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
اندريا مات اشار الى ان كل الدفاعات تعمل
الدفاعات الجويه في عموم اوكرانيا وكذلك
شركه الطاقه الاوكرانيه تحدثت عن انها
ستعمل على ادخال القطاع طارق للتيار
الكهربائي تحسبا ل اي ضربات قد تستهدف
البنا التحتيه في العاصمه اكياس اذا هذا
هو الوضع حاليا صباحا كان هجوم صاروخيه قد
استهدف ايضا منطقه همم قال رئيس الاداره
الاقليميه همم لقياس انه استهدف منشاهده
للبناء التحتيه ولكنه لم يحدث فيها دوارا
كبيرا ولم يفرض عن وقوع اصابه كذلك حطام
بعض الص الاخوه شظاياها صابت بعض المناطق
اصابت سيارتين ومستودعا مع معدنيه ولكن لم
يفيد عن دمار كبير او حتى عن اصابات
اللافت ما قاله همم المتحدث باسم القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه همم اليوم همم بعد حدوث
هذه الهجمات الصباحيه من انه متاكد من ان
هذه الهجمات التي استهدفت كهف صباحا همم
اتت من الاتجاه الشمالي من شمال اوكرانيا
ورجح ان تكون همم ان يكون نوعها اما
صواريخ بالستيه او صواريخ اس 300 مضاده
للطائرات ولكنه اشار الى ان المختصين
سيعملون على تحليل حطام الصواريخ لتحديد
نوعها ايضا همم هنا تشدر الاشاره الى ما
قاله بشان تحليق طائرات روسيه استراتيجيه
من نوع كيو 95 في اجواء اوكرانيا تزمن هذا
الكلام طبعا مع همم اعلان الانذارات
الجويه في مختلف مقاطعات اكياس سواء في
الشمال او حتى في الجنوب حيث اعلنت
القيادات العسكريه في تشارنهاش شمالا
وكذلك في خرسان وميكو لايفولوجيا جنوبا
ايضا حاله الانذار الجوي والاستنفار وتمت
دعوه المواطنين الى اخذ الحيطه والحذر
واخذ هذه الانذارات على محمد الجد
والاختباء في الملاج ايضا مفيده من قياده
عمليات الجنوب جلال بان همم هذه
الاستهدافات الان في فتره بعض ظهر همم
مصدرها البحر الاسود علما ان الجيش
الاوكراني كان قد افاده عن ان القوات
الروسيه تعمل على زياده قطاعها البحريه في
البحر الاسود ورفعت العدد الى سبع سفن
بينها سفينه انزال وايضا سفينه تحمل
صواريخ اذا هذا هو الوضع حاليا مع العلم
ان همم الانظار كانت تتجه بشكل اساسي منذ
ايام الى جبهه سولي اا سوليدار بخموت هذه
الجبهه ما زالت مشتعله ايضا اليوم تم
الاعلان عن ان المعارك ما زالت مستمره وان
الاشتباكات تحصل بشكل مباشر ومازالت
اوكرانيا تنفي ان تكون قد تمت سيطره روسيا
عليها بشكل كامل نستمع الان الى ابرز ما
قاله المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه
سيعرف المختصون منه الحطام نوع الصواريخ
التي استخدمها العدو لكن من الواضح ان هذه
كانت اما صواريخ وبالسيه او صواريخ 300
مضاده للطائرات ولكن المؤكده ان العدو هاج
مكيف من اتجاه الشماليه جاءت تحذير من
التهديد الصاروخي متاخرا بسبب نقص في
بيانات الرادار ولسوء الحظ لا تمتلك
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وسائل فعاله
لاكتشاف الصواريخ البالستيه وتدميرها
قال قائد مجموعه الاستطلاع الجويه تكتيكيه
الاوكرانيه ان القتال ما يزال مستمرا كما
قال القائد العسكري ان العالم الاوكرانيه
ما يزال مرفوعا في القسم الغربي من
المدينه
العالم
تجري حاليا عمليات قتاليه واشتباكات
مباشره وقصف مدفعي متبادل حاول العدو
الالتفاف على سوليدار من جهه الجنوب
والشرق لكنه لا يستطيع انجاز ذلك نحن
مستمرون بالتمسك في
مواقعنا الحاليه لا تسمح لنا بالوصول الى
وسط المدينه وايضا لا تسمح لقوات فاجنر
بالدخول الى هناك
رانيا ما الذي تقوله الدفاع الروسيه عن
واقع الجبهات لا سيما اييه ما يحصل في
سوليدار
الدفاع الروسيه اليوم لم تتناول على
الاطلاق جلال مساله تطورات الوضع في
سليدار فالاعلان كان رسميا يوم امس ووزاره
الدفاع روسيه قد اكدت سيطره القوات
المسلحه الروسيه الاسيمه قوات شركه فاجنر
العسكريه الخاصه على لدار بشكل كامل فضلا
عن ذلك اودى الاشاره لانه العديد من الصور
صور الفيديو تم التقاطها اليوم وتم نشرها
في مختلف وسائل الاعلام من قلب مدينه تظهر
همم تنقل القوات بادن في قلب هذه المدينه
برفقه الصحفيين الروس وتظهر هذه الصور
الفيديو ايضا يعني يمكن القول العشرات من
الجثث كل مكان جثث القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه همم فضلا عن ذلك كانت هناك
معطيات رسميه عن السيطره على هذه المدينه
منذ ايام ولكن امس تمتاكيد على السيطره
على هذه المدينه هذا فيما يتعلق بالمساله
التطورات الوضع في سالدار اما على صعيد
مختلف جبهات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اكدت ان
العمليات العسكريه مستمره هناك النجاحات
حسب تعبيرها ملموسه في جبهه دانياتك همم
الحديث يدور هنا عن تقدم القوات المسلحه
الروسيه نحو همم مدينه سول هناك حديث عن
تنفيذ عمليات وعمليات هجوميه ناجحه للقوات
الروسيه بحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بدعم
من قبل قوات الانزال وايضا السلاح الجوي
الروسي وعلى هذه الجبهه على وجه التحديد
تم القضاء على نحو مئه عسكري اوكراني في
مقاطعه عن القضاء على مئه نحو مئه اخرين
في مختلف الجبهات والحديث يدور هنا
بالدرجه الاولى عن همم محوريه
ايضا عن وايضا عن محور الكريسماس نيمار في
ما يتعلق همم بمدينه باخم وهي التي تبعد
نحو 15 كلم عن مدينه سلدار بالفعل الاوضاع
هناك محتدمه للغايه همم بالروسيه تحدث عن
توجه القوات المسلحه الروسيه ومقاتلي شركه
فاجنر
لاحكام احكام محاصره وتطويق هذه المدينه
هناك معارك داميه تجري في المناطق الشرقيه
يعني في المناطق والمدن والبلدات المتاخمه
لهذه المدينه من الجانب الشرقي هناك
عمليات تمشيط وتعزيز للدفاعات للدفاعات
الروسيه في هذه في هذه الجبهه ناهيك عن
سيطره على بلدات من ناحيه الشماليه ومن
الناحيه الجنوبيه ضد الاشاره بان مساله
الشيطره على ذلك بحسب ما اعلنت عنه امس
وزاره الدفاع الجهاد كانت قد اكدت ان
السيطره على دار سيسمح للقوات الروسيه
بالتقدم واحكام السيطره وبالتالي احكام
تطويق وبالتالي السيطره على مدينه
الاستراتيجيه التي تعد لها احد اهم معاقل
القوات المسلحه الاخرى ان هي في خطا
الدفاع الاوكراني في هذه المنطقه شكرا
رانيا في موسكو